fall et mathis journalistes et
spécialistes des institutions
européennes bonjour monsieur mathis
merci d'être heures en direct avec nous
alors le temps presse outre le
calendrier les eurodéputés demandent et
une conclusion des négociations à minuit
jusqu'à quand selon vous les
négociations peuvent-elles encore durer
c'est toute la question il faut bien
comprendre qu'on est à la conjonction de
deux événements extrêmement important
qui tous les deux marques l'isolément de
plus en plus grands d'ailleurs de la
grande bretagne par rapport à l'union
européenne
il ya bien sûr le blocus continental qui
est en train d'être opéré avec la grande
bretagne pour tous les voyageurs qui
viennent de grande-bretagne mais qui n'a
apparemment aucun rapport avec les
discussions sur l'aubrac site
je dirais qu'il ya quand même un rapport
et ce rapport c'est que le poids qui
pèse sur les négociations change de
nature
il est important pour les négociateurs
aujourd'hui de considérer qu
effectivement il faut pas en trop
rajouté sur la barque est quand qu il
est nécessaire d'avoir un accord donc je
pense que véritablement il ya une
volonté réelle qui n'existait peut-être
pas il ya encore quelques semaines qu'il
ya une volonté réelle d'aboutir à un
accord au moins un accord minimal
puisque il est vraisemblable qu'on
n'aura plus le temps
d'ores et déjà de procéder à des
ratifications cet accord parce que le
délai très bref une d'ici le 31 décembre
mais comment on pourrait trouver un
accord provisoire qui pourrait être
ratifiée après le 1er janvier sur les
points qui restent à négocier
effectivement là les discussions et
c'est ça le problème
les discussions restent que difficile
parce que sur un point en particulier
celui de la pêche c'est à dire le
partage des eaux de pêche entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne est
bien le désaccord est encore très fort
et on n'est pas encore au niveau d'un
accord possible
je rappelle quand même tout simplement
contre les deux l'équation est simple
pour les européens c'est se dire les
britanniques veulent récupérer leurs
eaux territoriales
soit mais dans ce cas là s'ils veulent
continuer à vendre leur poisson vers
l'union européenne
il faudra dans ce cas là qu'ils
acceptent que les pêcheurs européens
puissent pêcher dans leur zone
l'équation elle est toute simple mais
elle est simple mais pour le
gouvernement britannique
l'important c'est de se dire nous
récupérons le contrôle de nous à faire
et c'est là dessus sur cette idée de
récupérer le contrôle que les
britanniques sont les plus exigeants et
c'est ce qui explique que l'union
européenne dit simplement britannique et
bien on peut pas avoir le beurre et
l'argent du beurre
en ce qui concerne à la fois récupéré
tout le contrôle et en même temps
vouloir continuer à participer au marché
unique
c'est une guerre d'usure entre les deux
camps aujourd'hui c'est une guerre
d'usure qui est limitée dans le temps
parce que des deux côtés on sait très
bien qu'on ne pourra pas aller au delà
de la semaine qui vient il faudra
trouver une solution une solution
moi je persiste à penser que c'est un
accord transitoire qui évitera évitera
le chaos parce que je pense qu'on peut
bien parler de chaos
si effectivement on arrivait à un
constat d'échec
d'ici là ça sera un chaos aux frontières
et puis je rajouterais une chose quand
qu'il est très important pour les deux
parties de partir de cette négociation
de la tête haute c'est à dire sans avoir
sans donner l'impression d'avoir perdu
dans une négociation c'est très
important pour les britanniques qui je
le répète veulent pouvoir dire aux
britanniques et bien nous avons réussi à
récupérer le contrôle de nos affaires et
c'est très important pour les pays de
l'union européenne de se dire le marché
unique ne sera pas menacé car à chaque
disposition que les britanniques
prendrait pour prendre un peu trop de
liberté vis-à-vis de leur accès au
marché unique
nous prendrions des mesures de
compensation art je pense notamment des
budgets en matière fiscale en matière de
taxe donc vous voyez tout le jeu est
encore relativement ouverts mais plus
pour très longtemps
il reste quelques jours elle l'europe et
n'est pas pressé les britanniques
semblent plus pressé mais deux ce qui a
changé par rapport à ces derniers jours
c'est que je crois que ces deux crises
simultanées
le cola co vide et d'autre part la
sortie du royaume uni ces deux crises le
fait qu'elles soient ensemble oblige les
deux parties a essayé d'accélérer pour
trouver une solution
quoi qu'il arrive la grande bretagne
sera perdante ce sont les mots de
thierry breton commissaire européen pour
le
marché intérieur ce matin votre avis sur
la question tout le monde sera perdant
la grande bretagne sera perdant l'union
européenne sera perdant de toute façon
ce break site sera perdant pour les deux
parties mais c'est vrai qu objectivement
la grande bretagne qui va se retrouver
seul à l'extérieur de l'union européenne
et donc dans une situation de moins
grande force de négociation vis-à-vis
des partenaires étrangers de tous les
autres partenaires et bien c'est elle
qui a plus à en souffrir elle à en
souffrir d'autant plus que c'est une île
et que le risque de voir des blondes des
frontières qui vont se bloquer par des
par les fils de camions et par des des
dispositions réglementaires qui vont
être extrêmement rigoureuse fait
qu'effectivement il ya un risque de
chaos dont la grande bretagne c'est vrai
risque de souffrir nettement plus que
l'union européenne merci beaucoup
françois poulet mathis avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes